لنفترض أن الولايات المتحدة لديها
مظالم مشروعة داخل إيران ،
فما نصيحتك لو
طلب منك الرئيس ترامب
وإدارته بشأن
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني والانسحاب
لأنه من الواضح أن هذا تسبب في هذا
التصعيد الهائل مع الضغط على إيران
من خلال حملة الضغط الأقصى الأمريكية
دعني أذكر
الجمهور بأن العقوبات قد تمت تجربتها
في العديد من البلدان ونحن في
العراق عانينا من العقوبات في
التسعينيات والدمار الذي
أصاب المجتمع العراقي لا يزال
مستمراً حتى اليوم - بالمناسبة  نحن
نشعر تجاه شعب إيران لأنهم
يتعرضون لهذه العقوبات
وهناك أيضًا سؤال أساسي
عما إذا كانت هذه هي الطريقة لإحداث
تغيير في السلوك في السياسة التي
يتم السعي إليها في الاتفاق النووي وقد
رحب بها الكثيرون في  المنطقة من قبل ما
رحب به الأوروبيون رحب
بها العالم كوسيلة لتجاوز هذا
المأزق هناك مشاكل مع  أن
الاتفاق النووي يحتاج إلى التفاوض
عليه أنه بحاجة إلى المناقشة وأن
البديل من إلغاء الصفقة يمكن أن
يكون كوارث للحي بأكمله
ليس فقط لإيران وليس فقط
للعراق بالنسبة للجوار ككل.